because I guess we bought a house this
is the reality of setting up a home
was this a crazy decision to do while
heavily heavily pregnant yeah
[Music]
it is a magical house
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's curious
mom and we just did the most wild thing
we've ever done in our entire lives we
just bought a house sight unseen clear
across the country in the Catskill
Mountains of New York now Matt and I
have about two weeks to completely
renovate and fix this house up before I
am physically not able to fly anymore so
we're gonna get started on doing that
and see if we can turn this house around
because it's a bit of a fixer so wish me
luck never done anything like this
before flying to New York for all of us
as a family is very expensive and so we
had to make the decision to wait to go
until after we had already found the
house it was still really stressful not
being there in person
I am about to get on an airplane alone
very pregnant with all of my children
I'm very nervous we took a red eye so I
think that helped the flight was pretty
painless and honestly my number one tip
for parents out there if you're flying
with your kids bring a bunch of
lollipops just each one will buy you 30
minutes of quiet we made it how was the
flight guys
so we land Matt picks us up and this is
my first time seeing the Catskills let
alone this house so we're on our way to
the house we're gonna see it for the
first time one two three turn around
it's just life-changing for all of us I
kind of shut down for a second it was
like oh my God that's our house are you
happy to be here yeah oh my gosh that's
awesome
so let's talk about why this house even
happened one Matt and I are wacky people
this was one of the most wild decisions
we've ever made I think the best way to
explain this is that I am a Cancer
Zodiac I love home I love having home
base I love just making memories and
everything revolving around the home so
it has always been such a dream of mine
to have another place that's like our
home away from home where we can go as a
family we can enjoy holidays and just
make special memories in another
location this house is on nine acres
half of it is absolute Forest but not
only that it has a half acre large pond
kids of course wanted to just take off
running exploring the grounds
blackberries oh my goodness look at this
there were blackberry bushes all over
the property my farm girl dreams are
coming true oh my gosh these are crazy
good the other thing about seeing a
house that you own that you need to fix
up is you can't help but just see work
to be done everywhere you look my work
is cut out for me
um so I'm just gonna start unboxing some
stuff I'm exhausted
the vibe I chose for this house was
Modern Farmhouse so I wanted everything
to look clean I wanted everything to
look simple so my plan in my head in
renovating this house was we would just
go room to room one room at a time and
do it at finish each one with a neat
little ball and move on to the next and
what I realized very quickly was it
wasn't going to be that way it was going
to be kind of a Mad Dash of like this
arrived set this up this arrived set
this up and just do what we can when we
can until the house is finished two fold
out couches complete
foreign
now the main thing impacted by this
timeline was the Furnishings I had to
order everything before I even left
before I'd even seen this house my
current huge dilemma I ordered
nightstands for all the bedrooms and one
pair just never shipped when I reached
out to customer service and I sent this
membership and they said okay we'll look
into it and then they got an email
saying we're sending you a replacement
and I look and it's gonna arrive when
we're gone so I had to cancel that
replacement nothing will ship in time
anymore I'm freaking out how are you hi
I was good I'm in my my little Lodge how
has it been restoring that house the
word I'd used to describe it is frantic
trying to get everything together and
it's been just non-stop work I have a
surprise for you I've been following
your Instagram stories and I see it
you're antiquing are you finding awesome
things I don't know why it is so hard I
cannot find a small nice stand so it's
been a game of Tetris getting all the
bedrooms together and I have one room
that has two twin beds that barely fit
and I have about this much space for a
nightstand and I cannot find anything I
found something that I think you're
going to love we bought it and I sent it
to your home I could cry right now
early I was about to go cut down a tree
and use the stump you're gonna love it
it's like definitely in the style that
we were talking about well I have to pay
you back so can I send you the money
with Zell is that cool yeah I use that
all the time with my family too I've
been using it so much since this whole
project started it has been a lifesaver
because the money will go to you just in
minutes it's so much easier to pay okay
you'll get it in a couple minutes I
appreciate it so much no problem at all
please be safe and we'll see you when
you get home all right bye
I was going through every single room
and thinking about what I needed to do
and then it would dawn on me I don't
know about vacuum I don't have light
bulbs I don't have soap I don't have
cooking utensils I don't have any of
this stuff I needed to make a trip to
town to get some Essentials we found
uh fans we found pendant lights for
outside wall sconces we did not find any
chandeliers we found a doorbell oh we
took pictures of the bathroom vanities
we want oh we got more paint
we got more paint and light bulbs
something that's so special about this
area is there are farms everywhere I am
at a farm stand
oh so cute so right at the end of our
street there is a gorgeous Farm Stand
with these giant tomatoes giant zucchini
corn and I had to stop and I had to get
some fresh produce oh my gosh you guys
look at this tomato and then I got two
zucchini and I got four corn and it was
seven dollars and I'm very excited we're
gonna cook this tonight I just made the
most beautiful plate farm Foods
cheese and then little foods from the
co-op smoked mackerel stuffed grape
leaves and cornichons and I'm going to
devour this oh look who's here what are
you gonna have grape leaf how is it
where's one of my giant tomatoes so
delicious look at what Matt's doing is
this Henry's work
give me one in the glass you want to
play run in the grass okay this is the
reality of setting up a home
[Music]
okay this outdoor table very nice I'm
building beds and I had to order these
before we even got here each bedroom has
these baseboard heaters that are
throwing me off I thought I had space I
toured all the bedrooms I saw that it
was going to be a really tough squeeze
with the beds that I had bought each
bedroom has baseboard heaters where you
cannot put a bed frame this bedroom
originally was gonna have two twins but
I can't do that because there is a
baseboard heater so there's just nowhere
for me to put two beds and the twin beds
are gonna go in here it's not perfect
this closet opens up as well it's gonna
be a tight squeeze this is why I'm
really feeling like we're not gonna get
anything done
[Music]
anytime I try to sit down and do
something
[Music]
another thing that definitely factored
into this burnishing is my pregnancy
brain sometimes I do this thing where
I'll order something and then forget and
then I'll be like oh I never ordered it
and I'll order it again
and again
and again let's look what happened I am
drowning in bath towels I firmly believe
you can never have enough towels a
couple or you know 60 extra towels never
hurt anybody we got the magical chairs
that we've been so excited about and
they're gonna go in the living room the
living room is like not even close to
done
but we're gonna set them up just to see
if they're comfy is it comfy
yeah I almost fall asleep for a second
oh my gosh that's beautiful too bad the
background it's so good
so
bad
[Music]
just because you're renovating a house
doesn't mean fashion goes out the window
fit check is this antiquing clothes I've
got my maternity overall wish us luck
please give us coffee table Vibes yeah
and bench and look how cool this bench
is the owner of the shop made it and he
used
charcoal left over from cooking to color
it so on the way back I had heard about
an amazing soft serve place in a little
town called Delhi we're in town
getting ice cream ice cream Saturday
night
they have 30 flavors of soft serve and
this is something that I surprisingly
can't get in the desert so I was so
excited for us to go I love soft serve
more than anything I think it is so good
what do you think it was cold it
definitely gave me some motivation to
really like get into gear and keep going
with this house
[Music]
having breakfast outside it's so nice
and we don't have a dining table inside
yet obviously we didn't have time for a
full kitchen remodel nor the budget
those remodels are very expensive so I
had to get really creative and think
about ways that I could improve this
kitchen brighten it up just make it look
a little more modern today I'm
attempting to start painting the kitchen
cabinets it's kind of been a time crunch
this isn't something that I was really
supposed to do but we gotta do what we
gotta do to get this done I'm doing this
padded sticky stuff for the kitchen
cabinets and then I got contact paper to
line all of these drawers so I ended up
having to take all the cabinets down
because they're lacquered with some
shiny thing I had to sand everything
primer it paint do a couple more layers
I was doing the painting by myself was
this a crazy decision to do while
heavily heavily pregnant yeah Matt has a
very important work deadline today so he
has been like just
in the weeds of work his full time
[Music]
I was starting to just feel the stress
creeping up back to work on the kitchen
I'm hoping so I got this whole section
done yesterday and I would like to get
this done today gosh if I'm like super
ambitious maybe no there's no way that I
can a girl can dream so our dishwasher
detergent lid wouldn't close it was
completely broken another random task
that I need to complete is this
dishwasher detergent to Spencer's broken
you see it won't
it won't lock so I ordered a new one and
it's a little bit more involved to get
this replaced but I think I can do it I
ordered the replacement part and I
couldn't get anyone out there to fix it
so I replaced the detergent container
are you ready for kitchen progress
because I'm kind of freaking out here
we're gonna go with painting all of the
cabinets white but then Matt had an idea
of what if we take some of the cabinets
off and see how it looks having them
open for some of them it's a very
cramped kitchen and so having all of the
cabinet doors closed felt a little
stifling so having them off actually
felt really open and it felt like we had
transformed the kitchen a lot more than
we actually had it's been a crazy long
day and we're gonna taste this sugar
cube melon that we got at the farmer's
market
it's yummy what do you think it tasted
Canada I have a purple thumb
wow look at my belly like blocking Henry
with my belly
[Music]
so some bad news they found that this is
all dipping and like collapsing so we
have to take everything out when they
started to repair the duck we all
noticed that that actual wall of the
house
was rotten Not only was the duck damaged
but it had gone all the way up the wall
so what started out as a simple duck
repair turned into knocking the entire
wall down replacing the slider replacing
all the broken tile and fixing the deck
at this point I have no wall
on my house there is a tarp instead of a
wall half the floor is done half is not
there's still so much painting left to
do and I'm thinking my goal of finishing
the house by the time I had to leave
just didn't seem attainable at this
point this is how we're eating
on the floor because we can't use the
kitchen today renovation meals are very
similar to moving meals it's a lot of
Frozen stuff it's a lot of microwave
stuff so we were eating a lot of hot
dogs and a lot of pizza every day we're
doing stuff I am also trying to find
ways to bond and connect and so the kids
had really wanted to make s'mores and I
figured let's just do it
how is it
I am gonna set up my first bedroom for
real like set up the bedroom Matt and I
get along pretty well but when you're
doing something like this and taking on
a project like this on a really tight
timeline there can be some friction and
so we were definitely fighting more over
stupid things one of which was that
wooden wall I was like paint it get it
done and he was like no when I got there
he had left it and it ended up being a
great decision nice
yeah it looks like it
[Music]
yeah
bedroom
down so with a bass Pond obviously comes
the need to fish Jackson thinks of
himself as a survivalist he's obsessed
with survival gear survival everything
and so this was his dream he immediately
got a fishing rod and he and Matt
learned together how to fish I'm like
City Slicker was trying to I hate bugs
oh my gosh you guys our city was
definitely showing as they were trying
to fish we'll get there that's the whole
point practice makes perfect and we'll
get there it's gone it's cool
[Music]
yes ready let's do our kiss our bird
kiss
thank you baby
something that I didn't think of when it
came to renovating this house was all of
the kids would be home with us and Henry
would need just as much as attention as
he usually does at home
okay let's let's go get PJs on come on
definitely struggled with Breaking Free
for a little bit to be able to do things
during the day and what ended up
happening was I do most of my work at
night after the kids were in bed now all
I wish is that it was light out when I
finished this because if you get the
full effect of this room simple and done
I'm showing it before the art is hung
because I'm not allowed to show you know
other people's artwork but I would love
to get a shot when it's like light
outside so you can see how beautiful the
view is from this bedroom
[Music]
it is pouring rain today I don't know if
this is a fun fact maybe it's a weird
fact about me I love cemeteries anywhere
we go to visit I want to go see like old
cemeteries I just love it so I just
wanted to drive through and see it we
have so much left to do
and four days to do it such a benefit to
being out here by all these Farms
because look at this tomato salad I made
it looks beautiful and I actually like
cooked I made some pasta so this is like
an actual meal and not a freezer meal
we're making progress everyone
today this day is all about the
bathrooms I'm gonna switch out all this
Hardware on this bathroom vanity looks
so much better the funny thing is when
Matt first got there he called me and
was like I think these bathrooms are
kind of fine I actually think it's okay
like we can just leave them as they are
and it's it's gonna be fine and then
when I got there I was like
excuse me so I had to get hardware and
the countertop for it and install all
that Hardware myself and these changes
were on the thriftier side and honestly
the difference it made in these
bathrooms was astonishing can you
believe this
so extremely proud of this hi
I can't believe it it's
just a few tweaks
[Music]
so at long last the floors were finally
finished the walls were finally painted
and we could start truly taking
everything out of the boxes and really
staging the rooms my big thing whenever
I'm staging a house or I'm Furnishing a
house is functionality I want all of the
spaces of the house to function and
serve a purpose final night and guess
what we're having pizza
we ordered some pizza to pick up we're
bringing it back I was a little sad that
we were finishing so last minute because
I wanted to enjoy it I guess the end
goal is that it gets done and that's
what happened
[Music]
so the major changes that we made to
this house were fully painting the
interior we did a white with black trim
we ended up ripping up a lot of carpet
replacing it with a hardwood Oak floor
we painted and removed cabinets in the
kitchen painted the backsplash we
changed out the toilets and vanities in
the bathroom we changed every light
fixture in the house to something a
little more sleek and modern and then
the rest was basically just Furnishing
this house is a fairly large entryway so
I wanted to create a space where people
could sit and take their shoes off you
go right into the living room and it's
like super comfy and cozy and all set up
there's a breakfast nook I'd say I most
proud of the dining room the way that
room came together the way we showcased
that stained glass window that had been
hidden before it's something I'm really
proud of so the first room is the twin
bedroom and it has two twin beds it's
perfect for the boys words cannot
express how much I love this little
table but Rob came through his tables
fit perfectly they were Sleek they were
modern they went in line with the style
of the house now the big room the big
Honker is the room with the king bed and
that's kind of the master bedroom it has
a desk the other thing I bought was this
massive faux cowhide I absolutely love
them then we have a queen bedroom
everything was a very tight squeeze in
that room but I was just so excited to
hang my palm Garland and then there's
one final bedroom off the kitchen it's
another queen bedroom it has its own
bathroom and so this is kind of what I
was considered during like a guest room
it was just a really happy ending to a
really grueling two weeks that totally
paid off bye house I don't want to leave
if we could each use one word to
describe this trip what would it be
amazing
amazing amazing amazing amazing amazing
amazing
at the end of the day the kids are in
love with this house it is so warm and
inviting as hard as this was to do I
feel nothing but gratitude to be able to
do it because what a special thing for
my kids to have growing up
oh my God
you gotta see
oh my gosh
wait let me get a picture oh my gosh all
this work was so that next time we can
come and we'll have our new baby and
we'll actually be able to take a trip as
a family instead of trying to juggle one
more kid with more renovation so that's
all for now I'm Hannah and tell me what
do you think of the house what do you
think it's missing what do I need to add
what do I have left to do let me know on
Instagram till next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]